when it comes to making music you
haven't collaborated extensively in the
past do you want to collaborate is that
a plan is that on the new record is
absolutely yeah I've only collaborated
one once before we have as a band every
seconds to mars collaborated with kanye
west yeah and it was incredible he was
fantastic and we ended up performing
together in Spain in front of 16,000
people but it was it was a really fun
I'd love to do it again yeah yeah I'm
fine if any Canadian artist that we can
pull in it was tons of unity yeah who do
you think I mean he can locate the
normal one I personally for me I think
thirty Seconds to Mars in the weekend
would kill it incredible he is a super
talent and yeah lovely light that would
just be like a pretty explosive VI yeah
when you do you find it you're in a
different position than other sort of
celebs because they tend to the story is
always you don't know what the world is
like because you're only New York in Los
Angeles but in a touring band you go to
smaller towns you travel America do you
feel that you having different
relationship with those people who
criticize Hollywood I think that it's
okay to criticize Hollywood yeah that's
not such a bad thing right I think that
when we do that we're taking a look at
ourselves you know and in also certain
parts of ourselves that we may not agree
with whether it's you know excess or
indulgent that's okay you know we can we
can take it sure but we when you are in
a band and you travel from Poughkeepsie
to Pittsburgh to San Francisco to Texas
to Kazakhstan to Oman to South Africa to
Brazil or whatever you do get a sense of
the world that's unique I mean you
haven't you have a perspective in it
and it teaches you about things that you
may not have known otherwise so I'm
really grateful that I have had that
exposure you know we've been coming to
Toronto I remember 1998 we played the
horseshoe yeah right and you know to
this day we have a really special
relationship with the city we've played
here so many times over the years and
the years and the years that it's
changed the way that we see this town
and the way we feel about it and we've
gotten to know the people of Canada from
extensive tours here in a really unique
way have you seen the new Blade Runner
trailer I haven't seen the new Blade
Runner trailer yet
I'm waiting you're waiting into what I'm
waiting I'm waiting you're not one of
those your own stuff you don't wash your
own I don't tend to watch my own stuff
and what was it I like was it awesome
making Blade Runner was incredible as it
may it was a dream it was a dream for me
Blade Runner is one of the best films of
all time and one of my favorite films I
go back to it all of the time yeah and
it taught me so much about
cinematography about directing about
acting about storytelling about music
and you know I always encourage people I
know I haven't seen the movie to watch
the movie so being a part of this new
chapter incredibly exciting working with
Harrison and to me and Ryan all these
incredible people
was fantastic and you know I'm on tour
now and I'm finishing my album now so
I'm not as much not you know
as much a part of the process with some
of the stuff but you know like Thomas I
really like but you dipped into that
world would you do Joker again have you
been asked that I come back to that
world you know talking about Joker is
like talking about Fight Club unless you
want to you know
gargle your testicles it's probably
better to leave it
yeah he's reliable to jump out of the
cupboard and you know start having fun